kylie jenner reacts to the tragedy that
unfolded at boyfriend travis scott's
astroworld concert on friday night in
houston a crowd-rushing incident leaving
eight dead and hundreds injured
kiley shared a statement to her
instagram stories saturday night travis
and i are broken and devastated my
thoughts and prayers are with all who
lost their lives were injured or
affected in any way by yesterday's
events and also for travis who i know
cares deeply for his fans in the houston
community the 24 year old went on to say
quote i want to make it clear we weren't
aware of any fatalities until the news
came out after the show and in no world
would have continued filming or
performing i am sending my deepest
condolences to the families during this
difficult time and will be praying for
the healing of everyone who has been
impacted kylie was at the music festival
with her and travis's three-year-old
daughter stormi she posted these videos
of travis performing on instagram
you can see where she and stormy were
located far above the stage and the
crowd during that tragic night some fans
have pointed out what looks to be an
ambulance in the crowd of kylie's shot
it's unclear if that was an actual
emergency vehicle though i just want to
send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost last night
travis himself was overcome with emotion
in a video he posted to his instagram
story on saturday you know my fans my
fans like my fans really mean the world
to me and
i always just really want to leave them
with a positive experience the sicko
mode rapper shared what his experience
was like as he was performing on stage
and started to notice distress in the
audience
anytime i can make out
you know anything that's going on you
know you know i'd stop the show and
you know help them get the help they
need you know he added that he could
never imagine the severity of the
situation i'm honestly just devastated
and
i could never imagine anything like this
just
happening
i'm gonna do everything i can to keep
you guys updated and
just keep you guys
informed on what's going on
love you all houston fire department
chief sam pena confirmed the eight
deaths during a press conference over
the weekend
and we had scores of individuals that
were injured here in this event he also
noted that 17 people were transported to
the hospital 11 of whom were in cardiac
arrest
pena added that 300 concert goers were
treated on location at the festival
which was held at houston's nrg park and
had around 50 000 in attendance
what we do know is that at approximately
nine o'clock 9 15
the the crowd began to to compress
towards the front of of the stage
okay and that caused some panic
and it started causing some injuries
people began to fall out
become unconscious
and it created additional additional
panic during the press conference
houston police executive assistant chief
larry satterwhite added that the chaos
seemed to happen all at once suddenly we
had several people down on the ground
experience some type of cardiac arrest
or some type of
medical episode
and so we have been we immediately
started doing cpr and moving people
right then satellite said that's when he
met with the promoters in live nation
and they agreed to in the concert and
interests of public safety the
astroworld festival itself later
releasing a statement on social media
cancelling the rest of the weekend's
performances